Let's get into audience questions for the
week and some really good ones.
First one is about these two special elections
in California and Wisconsin.
The question is, hey, David, do California
and Wisconsin special elections going to Republicans
mean an inevitable disaster for Democrats
in November of 2020?
The answer is no.
So if you've not been following these two
races, you had the 7th Congressional District
in Wisconsin and the 25th Congressional District
in California.
Two special elections.
Both went to the Republican candidates.
Mike Garcia defeating Christy Smith in California's
25th Wisconsin 7th, went to the Republican
candidate, Tom Tiffany.
So let let's talk first about California and
then about Wisconsin.
But before we even do that, special elections
tend to have low turnout.
And in particular, we know that one party
benefits from lower turnout.
Republicans benefit from lower turnout.
So you have to be very careful about taking
especially not just any special election,
but in the case of California's 25th, a special
election in a historically red district, at
least when it comes to members of Congress
and saying, hey, alert, low turnout, special
election went to the Republican.
This spells trouble in the fall.
It could.
There could be trouble in the fall for Democrats
and for Joe Biden in the 25th.
But this is not evidence of it.
So let's start with California, 25th, California
25th is this district that was held by Democratic
Congresswoman Katie Hill.
Katie Hill ended up resigning.
She resigned because she was involved in a
relationship with a staffer there.
Nothing illegal took place, but it does violate
House ethics guidelines.
And so she resigned.
So a couple of things then went on.
You had this jungle primary for the November
race simultaneously with the special election
primary.
You with the special election, you had a blowback
effect where this is, you know, they call
it a purple district.
But this was a seat that was held for 25 years
by Republican Buck McKeon and then for four
years by Republican Steve Knight.
They call it a poor purple district, but it's
been a Republican held district at the congressional
level for a really, really long time.
And then it went to Katie Hill, and Katie
Hill had to resign.
And there was a blowback effect to some degree
that has nothing to do with what we would
expect to see in the fall.
So that's number one.
Republicans are seeing the headline as, hey,
a Republican won a seat that was just held
by a Democrat.
This is great for Republicans.
The real story is that Katie Hill had taken
the seat that had been held by Republicans
for a really long time.
And it doesn't tell us that Trump is going
to start winning blue states in 2020.
Then you get to Wisconsin's 7th.
I actually think that Wisconsin 7th, although
it got less attention than the California
25th, is more relevant for thinking about
2020.
If you look at the results of the Wisconsin
7th special election just recently and compare
it to how those areas voted in 2016, there
was really no major shift.
If you look at the elements that make up the
Wisconsin seventh and you look at how did
they vote on Trump versus Hillary in 2016
and how did they vote for Tiffany versus the
Democratic challenger in that recent special
election that you could say, well, maybe I
believe it's pronounced a naida or Anita.
Anita County.
That might be a flip that came within 20 votes
in the judicial election that just took place.
It's going to be pretty similar to 2016.
So Wisconsin 7th is potentially more consequential
when thinking about 2020 because any small
change in Wisconsin could flip the state.
When you look at California, you can argue
about California's 25th as a sort of guidepost
for what might happen.
Bigger picture in California.
But Trump's not going to win California no
matter what.
Right?
Katie Hill resigned.
She was a Democrat, now a Republican, won
in a Republican state four decades before
it was Katie.
It doesn't matter because Biden's going to
win California.
In Wisconsin, even these small shifts, the
margin was small enough in Wisconsin.
I don't remember exactly what I think was
about 20000 votes.
That is a state that if the wind blows one
way versus the other, if older voters abandoned
Trump and go to by the way, we've been seeing
you could actually get a different result
where Donald Trump doesn't win Wisconsin.
So I don't think either tells us what is in
store for November.
But if I were to look at one of them as maybe
being a more impactful signal, it would be
looking at Wisconsin seventh, not California's
25th.